please welcome our host ted bellacor
thank you thank you nannies they touch
our lives in so many ways and tonight
reasontv acknowledges those who make it
their business to mind your business and
it's long been a male-dominated field
but for the first time in history most
of the nominees are women but don't
worry James Cameron your ex isn't in the
running for this award anyhow the
nominees for nanny of the year are Katie
Hobbs the arizona state Rep sponsored a
bill that would force advertisers to
warn consumers when models are
airbrushed to make them more attractive
Louisa Marie a Republican Party leader
in Asbury Park New Jersey who's pushing
the City Council to enforce a long
ignored law that bans bikinis and other
swimsuits on the boardwalk Bruce gates
police chief in middleboro Massachusetts
who spearheaded a new ordinance that
finds folks for swearing in public and
the winner is what that wasn't even out
of a graduation the global morality
statute police chief days this is cheap
dates first nomination and award
the chief couldn't be here tonight but
he prepared a brief speech we have a lot
more important things to do but these
are things that quality of life issues
here's to you chief your refusal to bend
to those who think that Judge Dredd is
the depiction of a future we should
avoid shows that you embody the very
spirit of banannie thanks for watching
folks that's it from Hollywood be sure
to check back next month for more
examples busybodies like your own
business